So how would constraint propagation be useful for Raven's progressive matrices?
This concept has a strong correspondence to the final project where
you'll be asked to reason over the images of the problem directly instead of
over the propositional representations that we've given you in the past. So
first, if constraint propagation leverages a library of primitive constraints,
what will your constraints be for the final project?
How will you propagate those constraints into the image to understand it?
Then once you've actually propagated those constraints, how will you actually
use those inferences? Will you abstract out propositional representations? Or
will you stick to the visual reasoning and transfer the results directly?